[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talked about oh my god oh really
now we're poor chiming it's crazy what
oh you crazy
sorry you know long hold now so we have
it for yourself yeah I'm pretty old
right well we're all more mature yeah I
haven't had like a gangster moment in a
long time you got angry recently not
angry but I was ready for some [ __ ] that
never happened I know because you just
are we gonna hear a war story so [ __ ]
preparing my mind it doesn't really
happen to me anymore
cuz I don't live in Glenda with a bunch
of Armenians where [ __ ] happens to David
all the time my life is really really
peaceful but the other day I was driving
back home from from our meeting at sip
in Pasadena but I was coming down from
Garvey going east yeah right where he
hit hits Atlantic I'm driving and I'm
about to hit the light and there's a car
that's just parked in the middle of the
street like he still has three car
lengths before he gets to the line where
he supposed to be yeah and his car's
parked and I just see his hand outside
the window off licking someone off he's
like yelling yelling yelling so I'm just
behind I'm on my own ass guys mad so I
was just waiting I didn't really care
but then the light turned green and he
kept yelling and I was just I'm just
gonna give him the time to just vent it
out whatever he keeps going on lies
taking to him forever
so I hit the honker is always called the
honker I think so
the horn and then he was still cussing
and then he started going forward well
no all right cool so now I'm just
driving or did we drive down past the
bank on the right and then this where
you're on Atlantic or going down Garvey
okay Oh Garvey Garvey oh yeah and so we
keep going down and now he's like
flicking me off he keeps turning around
like going crazy I mean oh yeah why for
no reason come on this [ __ ]
I don't know what the hell is happening
and then we just keep going and then he
starts breaking me like a [ __ ] wah
wah and then I can hear my stop I can
hear my duffel bag on the back of my
truck fly all the way back ahead that's
how hard I'm getting break check whoa
not a duffel bag where you might will
you bleed by yourself myself I'm like
this is [ __ ] crazy my dad this fool
is like really trying to like hurt my
feelings or something so so we keep
that's offensive yeah so we keep going
and then he pulls over he pulls over and
then I looked at him and then he's going
like this to me stole a freaking me out
yelling at me what does he look like
like some like Mexican do with like a
backwards hat covered was it blue I
couldn't I couldn't off the bill was a
different color from the actual head
part I couldn't talk but he so he was
there as like freaking me off and then
he goes behind me now he's hi beaming
the [ __ ] [ __ ] he's having me in the [ __ ]
out of me and still young and honking oh
my god
and it's all I was driving I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm like I feel bad for this month
because I've been training my ass off if
we get on this car i'ma beat the living
[ __ ] but it's like I can't wait I'm
gonna beat the living [ __ ] out of this
[ __ ] right but then as we go as
we go further down all night this guy
might actually just be crazy so I go my
backseat I pull my backpack i unzip my
back I got my hand on my gut and I'm
like all right he did not know what are
you looking forward to I think this if
we get to the next to the next light and
he gets out of his car yeah imma [ __ ]
smoke this fool if he comes to my to my
driver-side and what was crazy is this
is like the most beautiful case of Karma
I've ever seen the myth the moment right
when I pull my gun out I see sirens go
on behind me and when it went on all
that oh [ __ ] are they fighting me cuz if
he pulls me over I'm gonna get smoked
but then I look and then he pulls the
other car over so I guess there's a cop
that's been just post it in the corner
and watch I just full going [ __ ]
crazy the whole time and like hi beaming
and honking and and doing all that [ __ ]
so he got pulled over us that's great
magic if you [ __ ] shot a wall the cop
was around
I know but it was crazy cuz I'll say I
never had like a quick moment in a long
you never know who has a gun - in LA cuz
every summer there's always road rage
cuz it just it's just hot and traffic
doesn't mix well yeah but then there's
always some type of incident that
happens violent crime yeah on the
freeway on the streets from traffic yeah
I haven't had one of those feelings in a
long time was it oh [ __ ] shits about to
go down
it's hard to know Amen people people
just have crazy road rage like my uber
driver what's this [ __ ] Korean guy
yeah he's so [ __ ] Korean his car was
literally shipped from Korea here
because his GPS was still in Korean and
it was a it was a Honda Insight
this dude [ __ ] every stop so there
was this other dude ins I guess he was
trying to get in technically I think the
Korean guy was wrong I wasn't really
paying attention but the guy was asking
to come in he just wouldn't let him in
so they just started going at it but
it's bull [ __ ] so do [ __ ] people get
raged out here dude in traffic
specifically in LA it's hard not to yeah
I can't picture you yelling at somebody
though me I could picture you dancing
off with somebody but not when I flee
people if I do it so they can't see me
cuz you're so sweet you would like
internalize it and then afterwards I
must see a dance piece about it on your
Instagram she's all like you guys don't
know but she was just in a fight earlier
she's like I call this traffic jam
[Laughter]
this represents the time when I so what
do you been up to [ __ ] just trying to
be better everything my knee is as a
lotion I know it's really late now but
it was did you like everything but one
level oh oh I guess I didn't like what
being presentable but like I didn't do
today but like what do you mean these
you're selling your merch yeah like so
freezing I was like I could get dressed
but I could also not but like everything
you do like if you do a video just make
it one level up either production or
like hopefully its production and
content-wise like I'm taking a stand-up
class now because I want to be funnier
whoo some dude
Jerry Katzman we do what you trying to
one-up everything in your life every
single thing damn that's a hard New Year
you trying not to sleep what you need so
I do one extra hour oh I don't know how
you could do so much extras I'm trying
it's hard out here for a pimp I failed
every single New Year's goal already
well we are this year last year I
thought you killed all your boss well my
new year's goal so much weight yeah but
that was a 10 year new year's goal it
didn't really work out my new year's
goal actually have like they have
rollover rates so they keep rolling on
over every time yeah sure that's why I
don't have goals you have
you know what happens you set yourself
up for failure ya wanna surprise
yourself with the accomplishments that
you do you just like it's great
everything's great
I was supposed to learn Japanese every
[ __ ] day this year happen depression
you're like I've set myself up for this
imaginary road and then I didn't make it
for me
the roads are everywhere and I'm super
disappointed because we're actually
going to Japan in a couple months and I
could have been brushed up by then could
have been helpful
you got me don't worry youself a couple
months that's good it's hard though
because like it's just a lot of anime
get that you already stopped yourself
it's just too much gaps right now Oh in
between learning yeah and so it's not
becoming consistent so and it gets
annoying because my girlfriend speaks
Japanese but she speaks too much to my
ass and noise me yeah I mean so now
every time I leave or something I have
to say he taking my side to say that to
her every time I leave now smells like
school everyday that's great that's cool
it's annoying
repetition helps you learn though yeah
she's so good though she's so good I
mean you have a helper just wants to
learn Japanese and I don't speak at or
at all yeah she was dedicated and she's
like you even helped me and I'm like I
know cuz like I don't know how that was
Casey - and I was Chandler and Cantonese
that's why sort of in Mandarin and then
now I'm not even learning anything me
I'm seeing them in the same boat as you
like I set myself up yeah
and then I feel okay
midwife emptier I'll cry everyone's
tears for you I'm gonna help you up for
a second okay get better at making
excuses for yourself one notch higher
when you make excuses for yourself you
don't feel bad because you you justify
all of your actions in your delusional
war like you're justified oh yeah wait I
have a tip for learning languages ooh
it's an app is duolingo yeah use that so
what I've learned about learning
languages just because when I when I try
to learn the best the best way that I've
learned to do it is it's literally
personal personal interaction yeah and
so there is this one for ease it's like
a website slash forum and they don't
actually sell a product but they teach
you ways on how to learn it through
learning it through with other people so
you get keywords and then every week you
have to go into a chat with somebody
from Japan and longish and they want to
learn Japanese so that's a good excuse
for hiring a japanese camgirl yeah yeah
so they you actually learned that way
too and so how merry old to me was she
learned how to speak her language is
really well by this kind of sounds a
little crazy but having a conversation
with yourself in the sense of if you can
ask some somebody a question or you want
to you're gonna have to know how to say
that in that language and respond back
yeah so for example like when we're
having a conversation like this she goes
well how would I say this in Japanese
and then she would lock that down and it
starts to become then you start to pick
and choose like oh these are actually
very common phrases yeah and you know
how to go back and forth on them exactly
so she knows what's what's said and
what's going to be reciprocated best
through a style it's just it's just hard
because you have to do that the
repetition but she also lived in those
countries for a while like immersing
yourself in the culture because I was
like in China for one month and I swear
to God I thought I started to understand
the context of Mandarin well I was
talking about I'm like oh I could I can
that word I heard that before and then
when you're just forced to be in it and
that's all you hear I think you start to
understand the funny thing was with her
I think Mariel told me that she actually
learned how to speak Mandarin better if
white guy in Taiwan oh wow yes he helped
her well here amber lives there till
this day so he's actually from Pasadena
in LA area and those so they would go
out let's say they're going to like
7-eleven to buy some [ __ ] people look at
him and then she they were look at her
and go but she doesn't speak any
Mandarin at that point and then he has
to translate but they still would talk
to her oh my god because they're
comfortable looking at her but he
actually said comfortable looking I
don't know about these face over here so
maybe you yeah but it's kinda cool
though like this it's weird like what I
always see learning a new language yeah
I forget how cool she is with that stuff
like she could speak Mandarin she could
speak Japanese handling that's so cool
you want to learn a new language mm-hmm
what language I wish I'd learned French
and that was so hard
yeah that means good morning in French
Italian because kind of similar to
Spanish and it's way easier no I took
six years though I was in Spanish Honor
Society tucked in you don't remember
anything you know of course that cuz you
don't use it even me I'm like I Spanish
was my first language and I'm forgetting
it cuz I never use it
great I want to learn Spanish so bad oh
shut up I do because guess what you know
in that situation you know when that guy
was cursing you out what if you roll
down that window and you just are
speaking fluent Spanish to him he woulda
been my work though the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] but he would be even
more eager he goes don't speak Spanish
homie [ __ ] you racial profiling [ __ ]
Tigers in that stage right now where
he's within between all three languages
oh so I can't tell sometimes if it's
gibberish or if it's Chinese yeah cuz
you'll tell me like he'll say like
boo-yeah boo-yeah boo-yeah and I'm like
what the [ __ ] can I ask them he goes oh
that means like don't y'all say oh yeah
and y'all say no I think I'll say yeah
all different languages like you know
the the JSE twins I'll chat with him
every now and then on his whim yeah so
she was telling me that they're kids
they're born in Australia everything
else but she only
speaks Korean to them so they're her
kids are actually in ESL right now oh
you so it's kind of weird and that's a
good thing though I do think it's a game
that they're gonna be a bilingual 100%
sure because they have to learn English
in the school system at ur what yeah now
I'm wondering it's like well maybe I
should just teach my kids Korean Spanish
my first language oh really yeah all of
our [ __ ] grammar sucks and you know
what we'll really get you to realize how
bad you aren't English having a podcast
oh my god listening back to my [ __ ] I'm
like dude that's not English you [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] you're incredible in English
no but I'd mess up my words a lot I used
to be a lot better when I used to read I
don't read anymore and that's the
problem reading that [ __ ] me up when I
was like younger that I was like holy
[ __ ] that's not the way say it I thought
I was Salman for salmon yeah oh yeah oh
that's a lot of spanish-speaking people
say so on it so there's a mom Salman
following you because you're always
improving yourself cuz like Eurasian you
feel [ __ ] muting your post cuz it'll
be some [ __ ] like she's like this she
goes well I just got books today and I'm
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] I know you're not
faking cuz you actually read I put up a
barn door today it was not by myself
although I wish it was I was just in a
Nike commercial you could see me
everywhere like what and she's not even
flaunting it either it's just that's
just who she is
and then I look at my life and I'm
laying in bed with cheeto crumbs on my
stomach you right after the Nike shoe
[ __ ] with my tears but you're very
proactive did Thanks and I've seen you
grow consistently it's kind of crazy
because like I think like if you really
look at the model of somebody who is a
very consistent person and consistency
is key and kind of understanding who you
are you would be the the best model for
it because you actually came in later in
on to youtube than I did and I came on
kind of late yeah so for you I saw your
come up so it was it was very gradual
it wasn't something that was huge that
blew you up you were very consistent
with it and you have a very strong fan
base and I think that's the best way to
curate content on this on this channel
that's - yeah
because you have longevity because
you're come up was just done by you
whereas other people come in and they
come in hard because they're like kind
of leeching off of other people yeah and
then they just kind of fall off
booty-shaking video which you very well
could you are a very hot girl there's
one video where my ass is very prominent
it's on d-trix this channel it's a dance
video oh three million views I was
seeing other the owner like all these
like young bloods are cup young bloods
whoever young the radio so like oh [ __ ]
they'll skyrocket up and if like four
million followers but I'm like what
happens in like five years from now it's
still going that yeah is it because
their gimmick is gonna is gonna die off
yeah and I'm like god I have so many
more followers but I'm like but I don't
know about it I don't trust it all the
way versus like it feels um crime in
Mount Everest of how slow it's been but
thank you for saying that because it's
like okay it's not all for nothing
yeah because well sometimes I look at
your stuff and I'm like okay you know
what this girl right here is a good
person
now how do I do this in my life yeah but
you're fat and following is actually
really great because they're they're
very not I want to say consistent but
they actually care about you
yeah I mean wise because you curated
your content very very well and it's
authentic so that very authentic and
it's that's cool branding them do yeah
right yeah it's not even so we I always
expressed this too it's not so much that
you need a million views you could have
10,000 views but if 10,000 people [ __ ]
with you heavy it's way more important
than having a million people watching
yes it's way different the interaction
like how they support you in the way
they do it especially with their dollars
and their support is it's completely
different so if any young creators out
there are thinking about just blowing up
on the scene you have to think about
longevity like how long will these
people watch you so you'll see a lot of
people with content on their channel
they'll have a million views and in the
next video six thousand views yeah why
is that it's because they're only coming
to your channel for that one thing and
then I hear to watch you as a person I
just want to have that big break leave
then leave sure that breaks when it was
hot no no but I'm just sorry ya press
your baby I feel like sometimes this is
the painful it's the pretty growing
social experiment go on chill I'm too
damn [ __ ] I don't know I care too
damn much for my own damn good sometimes
well like we're too ahead right yes now
all of the you know role reversals and
the things they're hot now they're hot
now and we were doing those skits 7 yes
7 8 years ago so it's like maybe you
know it just wasn't the right time or I
don't know I'm gonna save my ideas bury
them and then do it later
yeah dig it back on my 7 years later
there there's like yeah parody
characters are - I don't know it's it's
different now you know it's the same but
different so
[Music]
you
you